[Musique]
je
que
il n'est ni de droite ni de gauche
plutôt défiant à l'égard de la politique
en général il y a trois ans tristan
démissionne de son poste de conseiller
funéraire pour se consacrer au combat
dès gilet jaune lassé de devoir payer
trop de taxes et après un an sans
activité il se met en quête d'un nouvel
emploi moi j'ai postulé j'ai postulé et
donc plusieurs entreprises me refuser
exemple dans une entreprise pas très
loin d'ici au bout d'une semaine ils me
disent combat mais sur les actes votre
contrat et redoubler très bien très bon
travail il n'y a pas de souci et
finalement on intimide plus tard il est
revenu me voir en disant ah mais vous
êtes triste en aux as que gilet jaune et
j'ai dit bah oui oui et là il m'a
répondu 2 voilà sauf que j'avais pas
d'enregistrement n'y avait pas de vidéo
il n'y avait pas de salariés autour donc
c'était très compliqué de le prouver
quand c'est comme ça on se tait petit
banques et d'entreprises soins au bout
d'un moment je pense qu'il faut aussi
comprendre pourquoi les gens s'engagent
dans des mouvements comme ceux comme
comme cela c'est des gens qui n'arrivent
plus à vivre au 15 du mois tristan
estime son combat légitime il ira
jusqu'au bout et ce malgré les menaces
de mort qu'il a reçu
des menaces de mort j'en ai eu de la
part de l'extrême droite et j'en ai eu
de la part de l'extrême gauche donc je
ne fais pas de différence je ne sais pas
qui sont ces personnes parce que à
défaut de me menacer de mort ils sont
pas capables de d'afficher leur nom et
prénom derrière c'est toujours par des
thés combien dé facebook cacher mais ce
père de trois enfants est déterminé le
19 janvier dernier il décroche un emploi
de chef de conduite à la coop des
masques
une aubaine de la valeur d'un smic qui
lui permet de faire vivre sa famille et
de payer plusieurs amendes pour
différentes entraves
c'est un peu plus de 500 euros damende
en touche et 3000 euros donc j'en ai
payé déjà une partie mais il me reste
cinq cents et quelques euros damende en
jours-amende et donc c'est vrai que si
je vais pas y passa se transforme donc
en peine de prison ferme donc voilà
aujourd'hui c'est important de pouvoir
ramener un salaire pour faire en sorte
de là deux payés et que je ne retrouve
pas en fermer aujourd'hui parce que
voilà parce que j'avais décidé de le
défendre une cause ce samedi il se rend
à paris pour défiler contre le pass
annie terre mais pas contre la
vaccination précise de gilet jaune
tristan a reçu ces deux doses de vaccin
anti qu'ovide son combat reste intacte
avec un rêve au bout être un jour
propriétaire de sa propre entreprise
funéraire